so who would do you think would win in a
fight ex or argal who or
argman ar
prob come
[Music]
on exists within the same universe
Kingsman so who would do you think would
win in a fight exie or argal who or ARG
ex Kingsman AR probably I mean I'm not
I'm not being biased I
think's going to win that fight yeah
duude to the nature he he's he's
idealized in that sense and so by that
very aspect everything is
extraordinarily casual and how he does
it and exy was sort of different exie
goes through the the growth The Growing
Pains of becoming a spy gu I mean I
prefer the Green Jacket to the orange so
well here's the thing here's the thing
about Argy technically he's an idealized
version of a spy which means that he's
not completely real and so whereas exie
is a real spy much like Sam's character
and so it's it's the fantasy the
Collision of the fantasy and the reality
is what's really really really fun but
at the end of the day the fantasy is
always going to to potentially beat the
reality he's he's wiry he's fast he's
wiry Scrappy he Scrappy but I based on
the scene and Mission Impossible I would
not I would not f with this man uh well
I mean that's true you say that listen I
love them both and have worked with them
both and they are both formidable in
that's a devil on Tong you're right
you're right so honestly it would just
be a fight to the death they would both
die they would both totally die but
Bryce you know you're a director
yourself you've directed episodes of the
menal
so what if one day Matthew vaugh asks
you to direct a movie in the kingsman
universe and you had to cast Henry
keville how would you think he would
Fair great of course yeah would you c as
AAL another character yes Henry Cav is
one of the best it'd be fun to be
directed by you yeah I would love I
would love to work with Henry Henry's
the best he's the best yes how about Sim
he's all right he's all he's all right
got to give a lot of line read have you
seen him dance I I tell
dance right now I'm dancing right now
very small move you can't you got to
like really look close subtle subtle
I'll take Sam Sam is one of the Sam is
one of the greats of all time I learned
I was telling him this yesterday I
learned so much about directing working
with Sam and just kind of seeing what's
possible for actors like how you can get
to a place where it's like yeah okay
this is the plan all of that but maybe
there's something better maybe there's
something more maybe there's something
that can be discovered and just being in
that playful space and mindset with no
ego just truly truly invested in just
making the most of every moment it's um
it was really really awesome getting to
work with him yes and you know Sam you
have a talent for improvisation so how
much of Aiden was scripted and how much
and how did it play against like Bryce
and Henry uh you know so the Improv is
tricky it really you you it needs to be
character based so it really is a
garnish for the main meal the main meal
being the dialogue in the script you
know I I I think the the best improvs
are always before and after the take
because you're trying to rev up the
engine and then you're sort of revving
down the engine so often those are the
best improvs actually you know when you
first say it was a meal I thought you
was you referring to yourself as the
meal and I was like H that is true
because you know you're kind I meant the
script being the meal the story the
story you are
no question thank you I'm sorry was
my yeah um Bry we about to say something
oh no I was just going to say like like
what do you said what do you remember
about the improvisation I was like often
on the other side of it and there was
just so many things many things that he
would say and true though we had a lot
of fun we had a lot of fun but like he
would say things and I would be like woo
that's edgy and then Matthew would be
like that's brilliant and then he'd be
like let's make a t-shirt of that thing
actually let's build it into the story
like there were constant things that he
would come up with and then it would and
then it would somehow become integrated
into the story and part of the fabric of
who the characters were and I just loved
it you're a risk taker I love it I love
it the last question is for you um so
did you know that this role I'm speaking
for myself completes every girl's dream
to see you as the greatest spy ever
James Bond or even as a bond villain
yeah so um would you ever take the call
if that happen you better um I I I I
have no idea what barara broccoli and
Mike Wilson are thinking and um
obviously it' be it'd be very exciting
to be a part of uh but uh watch this
space I mean it's it's I wish them all
the luck in the world regardless what's
fun is that AR guy is very very
different from any other spy you've ever
seen in in movies very very very very D
yeah yes yes and so and Henry has a
tremendous amount of range and I would
love to see you as Bond but anyway I
love to see you as a Bond girl opposite
Henry oh my goodness yeah sure sure
Barbara call
me little little long in the tooth for
for B girl silly I'm about to call him
asking can I be a Bond
[Music]
girl
n